alle meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen hier heute endlich mal wieder
zu einer neuen folge
in der heutigen folge oracle mit luca
geht es um diesen kommentar von wasser
und zwar schreibt er macht bei dem
nächsten mal einfach nix und ignoriere
alle also ich werde jetzt einfach mal
auf oracle dot com gehen werde dort bei
den interessen luca eingeben und wenn er
dann einfach die ganze zeit so schauen
los geht's
[Musik]
euro
2000 jahre später fertig
[Musik]
ich mache heute eigene folge wo ich
versuche alle leute die ich treffe zu
ignorieren
aber dort gewesen als ich mich bewegt
habe ihm komponierten fakten kommen
möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen
[Musik]
nein ich habe ständig gewillt ist ja
nicht so schlecht darin ja nie was hat
es denn gelegen muss ich ja weil ich
gelacht habe oder oder was du warst du
[Musik]
ja ich muss mir das hat geklappt
wie geht es hier ja jetzt beschützen
möchte ich hier gesehen habe blut von 1
30 ab seine oma kommt gerade rein tut
mir leid ich weiß auch nicht
[Musik]
hab ich dich gerade erschreckt nicht
wirklich damit konnte ich nicht ob sie
echt zunächst ehrlich wenn du nichts
gemacht hat geklappt da habe ich es doch
hingekriegt ich hab mir da noch ein paar
minuten gequatscht dass man mit jedem
von euch so wenn ich euch mal merkel
getroffen haben sollte und dann
allerdings passieren eine tastatur ist
grade kaputt gefragt
man kann am tippen und auf einmal fällt
ihr dieses ding von meiner tastatur ab
alter ich könnte heulen meine tastatur
schrott na ja gut er wir machen weiter
mit dem nächsten regen menschen ganz
kurz 30 regionalliga kommt dass in dem
video ja dass hier auch hundertprozentig
ja dass hier kann ich auch einpacken
wenn du noch irgendwas durchs schwarze
jeans rein erzählen willst geht man um
die ecke ist nicht da uns jetzt die
alice hier mit ihrem wundervollen wird
zumal fall unterhalten hat tue ich jetzt
ein gefallen und grüße die merle also
mehr ganz liebe grüße war das gut so
perfekt dass schneide ich dann raus
[Musik]
aid ruft wieder leute drücken mich
einfach
[Musik]
hallo alles klar zum ende hin ignoriere
ich jetzt noch eine person aber komplett
als ich setze nicht auflösen und werde
einfach gucken wie sie dann darauf
reagiert
[Musik]
was hast du da im hintergrund stehen ist
das ein geschenk ja das hat meine mutter
von ihrer arbeit bekommen geschenk steht
rechts er zeigt noch links orientierung
ist da bekommen die geschenke scheiße
alter wieder vorbei die opfer bin ich
eigentlich nie bei mir dürfen leider nur
schöne leute ins video ist natürlich nur
ein spaß freunde genauso wie die ganzen
anderen dummen beleidigungen und setzen
keine ahnung was die ich auch heute
wieder raus gehauen habe unter dem
letzten comic video kamen viele
kommentare von wegen luca du bist echt
was so gemein zu deinen zuschauern das
ist einfach mal ironischen humor und ich
glaube dass die meisten leute das auch
verstehen
von daher bitte nehmt das ganze hier mit
humor und mit spaß und sieht das ganze
nicht so ernst
aber das was jetzt mit dem heutigen
video wer durch die heutige episode
oracle mit luca gefallen hat und ihre
nächste woche einen neuen pfad haben
wollte das unbedingt einen daumen hoch
unter diesem video hier da schaffen wir
50.000 like dass der mega krass schreibt
mir mal zudem und in die kommentare was
ich in der nächsten folge machen soll
also heute habe ich ja fans ignoriert
was soll ich in der nächsten folge
machen schreibt sie die kommentare und
abonniert main kanal falls noch kein
teil der luke seid denn dadurch
verpasste keine videos werden
[Musik]